hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell and we are
bringing you the et interview then
gratulations
just what's going through my finally max
finally you won the disco ball I mean I
mean I don't know man it's like I said
it's just a lot of a lot of emotion I
want to keep it private I want to keep
it personal but there's just so many
people involved into this it's not just
about three people deciding whether you
win or lose it's about millions of
people calling and voting and you know
staying overnight and it's just
incredible amount of people that we
never will meet and this is their trophy
they won this is not your last season
please tell us you're coming back to
Dancing with the Stars I don't think so
really why not
this is exhausting it has nothing to do
with the win it's exhausting it's not I
don't know I mean the first thing that I
did after hugging her getting down the
Shelf of tony and ralph's shoulders was
I come up to Derek and I was like dude I
don't know how you do how he did it two
five five times I have no idea